Hey youtubers it's Charlie and since there
were so many Daleks in the Series 8 trailer
that just posted I wanted to do a video for
my favorite Daleks. There have been over 13
different people in the last 50 years to play
Daleks and if you count Dalek Oswin that number
goes up to 14. In modern Doctor Who usually
Nicholas Briggs is credited with all the Dalek
Voices, even variations on the normal Daleks
like the Prime Minister we saw in the Series
7 opener.
Hello any new people, if you're finding me
for the first time I do Doctor Who every week,
be sure to subscribe to get everything. I've
got a lot of special stuff planned for when
the episodes get here.
So before I do my list here's a quick history
lesson on all the Dalek Voice actors. Most
people just know about Nicholas Briggs but
there are a ton more.
The high pitched Dalek Voice was created by
two actors named Peter Hawkins and David Graham
for their first appearance in Season 1 episode
2, just called "The Daleks". The voice that
they came up with was modified by Brian Hodgson
to give it that mechanical sound.
You can actually watch a re-telling of them
doing this in Mark Gatiss' Adventure in Space
in Time. The docu drama about the creation
of Doctor Who. If you haven't seen it, it's
amazing, David Bradley plays William Hartnell.
After those three people, there were 7 different
people who did Dalek Voices for brief periods
before Nicholas Briggs took over in 2005.
There have been 5 different voice actors to
voice Davros, who isn't technically a Dalek,
but I usually include the character whenever
I talk about Daleks.
Here are my top 10 Favorite Dalek characters.
This isn't a power ranking, it's just my own
personal list of favorites:
Starting with number 10 - Oswin Oswald Dalek
This was a really fun twist on a Dalek and
I have to give it to Steven Moffat for trying
to tell a Dalek story in a whole new way despite
Russell T Davies already having mined a lot
of Humans as Daleks story material.
It's still a big question mark in the series
and I'm hoping we get a call back to it in
series 8. Supposedly Dalek Oswin was destroyed
when the Dalek Parliament destroyed the planet
but it seems like whenever Time Travel is
possible and there are cracks in the universe,
you never really die.
The interesting thing about Dalek Oswin was
that supposedly she was one of the fractured
reality Clara's that were created when Clara
Oswald jumped into the Doctor's Timestream
in the series 7 finale.
All of the versions of Clara seemed to retain
all the memories of the first version of clara.
So if that were true, why did Dalek Oswin
not know the Doctor in Asylum of the Daleks.
She seemed like she was learning about him
for the first time.
The only explanation based on what we know
now, is that Oswin Oswald when she was still
on the Alaska as a human, knew what was going
to happen. And then as a result of being converted
into a Dalek, lost those memories.
Number 9 - Davros from Genesis of the Daleks
(Michael Wischer)
This is the Michael Wischer version of the
character. It's just fun to watch any of the
classic Davros scenes since the style of writing
was so different. Because they didn't have
the special effects or huge sets that you
see today all the action was in their crazy
monologues.
It's much more Davros as mad scientist, like
Frankenstein meets Doctor Who. So you spend
a lot more time relying on your imagination
to conjure the things he's talking about.
Now they can just show you, but sometimes
it's better when Davros just talks about tiny
microscopic organisms reigning supreme and
your own brain hallucinates something epic
that they could never do on a tv budget.
Number 8 - Metaltron from Series 1
This was the first new Dalek to be seen since
the 2005 reboot and the beginning of Russell
T Davies love for humanizing the Daleks. Metaltron
was also the first new survivor of the Time
War the Doctor found. Even though there ended
up being several more the Tenth Doctor met.
I think this was also the first time we learned
Daleks could regenerate themselves by absorbing
time energy. Rose explained to Mickey later
that they had evolved to use background Time
Vortex radiation to restore themselves during
Doomsday.
I loved how absorbing Human DNA started to
make them all go mad, just because they couldn't
handle all the feels that came with Human
emotion.
Number 7 - Prime Minister Dalek
This was the one from Asylum, the Series 7
opener. I always love seeing the Khaled Mutants,
everytime I see one I always think of Dalek
Caan, but really they're just what the organic
The cool thing about the prime minister in
this episode was that he was begging the Doctor
for help. Everytime we see Dalek's again you
can just feel the pressure to do something
that hasn't been done before.
The Doctor had worked alongside Daleks before,
but I can't remember the last time they asked
him to save their race. Most of the time they're
just trying to kill him.
And the big twist really ended up being him
getting erased from their memory banks. Even
though they rediscovered his identity before
the Christmas Special last year.
Number 6 - The new White Supreme
This was Stephen Moffat's new take on the
Daleks, the New Dalek Paradigm. I should really
include all of them in this one. Outwardly
they were most notable for the reskinned colors.
Just because most of them previously had the
traditional gold look.
The Daleks that created the new paradigm were
explained as survivors of the Medusa Cascade
during the Tenth Doctor's run.
I think they mostly followed up on the New
Paradigm daleks in the video game City of
the Daleks.
Number 5 - Dalek Emperor from Parting Of Ways
This was the God Emperor of the Daleks. Which
kind of makes me think of God Emperor of Dune.
The Frank Herbert Story. It's always cool
to see variations on the Dalek casings, his
in this episode even had a little throne.
It ended up being another twist on Daleks
as Humans with Human Emotional problems. The
emperor got so crazy when Rose suggested that
the Daleks were part human because of all
the dna they had harvested.
He ended up creating an army of about 500
thousand Daleks that Rose was only able to
destroy when she became the Bad Wolf entity.
The emperor was so much fun mostly because
of the hubris. I mean, if a being really were
perfect wouldn't it not care about anything
everyone else was doing or whether or not
people acknowledged it as
a god?
Number 4 - Human Hybrid Dalek Sec
He was kind of a potential twist on the Davros
character. Trying to fundamentally alter the
Dalek Race and make them all more human in
a literal sense.
I loved how he was awakened to this new reality
after being bonded to a human, started explaining
his radical new theories to the Cult of Skaro
and they all kind of looked at each other
and were like "Nope"! and vaporized him.
It's a classic science fiction narrative that
anyone with new ideas immediately gets punished.
Number 3 - Davros from Stolen Earth and Journey's
End
This version of Davros was rescued from the
Time War by Dalek Caan. Previously Davros'
mind had been sublimated by a Dalek consciousness.
So that he was Emperor of the Daleks, but
there was a Dalek mind operating his body
and Davros' own consciousness was riding passenger.
So when we see him for the first time in Stolen
Earth, he's just re-taken control of his mind
and is working with the Daleks inside the
Medusa Cascade.
Anytime Davros appears it seems like the stakes
have to be raised. This time it was destroying
the multiverse so that only Daleks would be
left.
I love how he cursed the Doctor as the greater
evil in the end. Like, yes I tried to destroy
several universes, but you Doctor, are the
real villain.
They used his speech in the last series 8
trailer, so it's hard to know how the series
is going to deal with him going forward, since
the last we saw of him was in a fiery explosion
on the crucible.
Number 2 - The Dalek Genesis Ark
This was technically not a Dalek itself, but
a device like the TARDIS that existed across
dimensions and time and space housing a massive
army of Daleks.
The reason they needed Rose or The Doctor
to open the ark was because it needed Time
Radiation transmitted by touch and even though
the Daleks have khaled mutants inside them,
they were supposedly incapable of touch.
It's like a nuclear device that will explode
Daleks all over the world. Which is funny,
because the master ended up using the TARDIS
in a similar way to bring the Toclafane to
earth.
They actually kind of remind me of Captain
Jack and his final Face of Boe form. Like
everyone is destined for some horrific end.
and my Number 1 Dalek - Dalek Caan and the
Cult of Skaro
My favorite Dalek Caan appearance was in the
Stolen Earth Journey's end two parter. After
he'd gone nutters. Caan is probably the most
interesting Dalek to me because he's a twist
on Bad Wolf, minus the super powers.
It's like he gained ultimate knowledge but
paid the ultimate price. Here's a timeline
of events.
We see him in Doomsday with the rest of the
Cult of Skaro trying to open the Genesis Ark.
They fail and escape to New York in the 1930s.
They create Human Hybrid Dalek Sec but it
goes sideways and Caan timeshifts out.
He travels back to the first year of the Time
War being the first person to break the time
lock. Saves Davros from the jaws of the Nightmare
Child and brings him to the Medusa Cascade.
In the process of that rescue mission, he
sees all of time and space and goes mad.
It's funny that the new Supreme during that
period called Caan an abomination.
Let me know who your favorite Dalek is and
what twists on them you're expecting in series
8.
I'm going to post my next bonus video next
weekend or sooner if we get new footage before
then. Be sure to subscribe to get everything.
They seem to be alternating casting news with
new trailers.
If you haven't seen it yet I just posted a
breakdown of the new Series 8 trailer. There
are a lot of Daleks, including a Dalek battlecruiser.
Click here for that. And click here to see
which other UK actors I'd like to see become
companions in the future.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tonight,
high fives!